[Música]
los seres humanos producimos en la
actualidad aproximadamente 330 millones
de toneladas de plástico al año según
las naciones unidas de 8 a 17 millones
de las mismas acaban en el mar
los objetos grandes como en las redes de
pesca abandonadas dañan a las especies
marinas que se quedan atrapadas en ellas
como por ejemplo las aves las tortugas o
los cetáceos
los fragmentos más pequeños son a menudo
ingeridos por la fauna marina incluyendo
aves peces también el plancton y
entrando a formar parte de la cadena
alimentaria y causando en ellos daños
que aún no hemos sido capaces de
cuantificar
y el caso es que a pesar de todo el
esfuerzo que se está realizando para
entender la magnitud del problema la
realidad es que aún no podemos dar
respuesta a preguntas tales como cuanto
plástico hay realmente flotando en
nuestros mares y océanos
donde se acumula y qué pasa con ese
plástico en el tiempo
donde desaparece son preguntas a las que
aún todavía tenemos que dar respuestas
en el año 2013 hasta el año 2018
estuve residiendo en la costa suroeste
de inglaterra durante ese periodo de
tiempo tuve la oportunidad de participar
como voluntario en la limpieza de playas
junto a la comunidad local la cantidad
de plásticos en esas costas es
impresionante
la basura marina llega allí arrastrada
por las mareas las corrientes y las
tormentas conmociona grafo de profesión
no pude evitar hacerme la siguiente
pregunta de dónde viene todo ese
plástico
mi mujer que fue la que me arrastro las
limpiezas de playas me dijo un día bueno
y tú que eres tan listo y trabajas con
satélites no puedes hacer nada al
respecto bueno yo personalmente pienso
que mi mujer tiene demasiada fe en mis
capacidades
pero su pregunta despertó mi curiosidad
hizo que me dijera a mí mismo sería
posible observar la contaminación por
plásticos desde satélites
porque si así fuera podríamos rellenar
ese vacío en nuestro conocimiento y
estar mejor preparados para abordar el
problema
las corrientes marinas se asemejan a un
complejo entramado de carreteras por las
cuales los plásticos que vertimos al mar
se distribuyen alrededor de todos los
océanos desde sus puntos de origen
con la información que tenemos sobre las
corrientes marinas y con ayuda de
simulaciones podemos saber dónde es más
probable que un objeto flotante acabe
transportados por las corrientes del
golfo los desechos vertidos en las aguas
de américa del norte llegan a las costas
de inglaterra y al y a las de otros
países de la región atlántica incluido
españa
no obstante pronto me di cuenta de que
había mucha menos información sobre los
plásticos en el mar de lo que pensábamos
sabemos que está por todas partes desde
la antártida hasta el polo norte en la
superficie de los océanos en nuestras
costas diferidos y lagos podemos
encontrarlo en los fondos marinos a 6000
metros de profundidad o más hay plástico
incluso en nuestra comida y el agua que
bebemos
sin embargo no sabemos cuánto plástico
hay realmente en el mar porque el océano
es simplemente demasiado grande como
para que podamos estudiarlo con los
métodos actuales
para resolver esta limitación y
trabajando junto a otros investigadores
creamos una comunidad internacional de
científicos que quería explorar las
opciones que los satélites pueden
ofrecer de cara a este problema y
averiguar qué tecnologías de las
actualmente disponibles podría servirnos
mejor para medir desde el espacio la
contaminación por plásticos en nuestros
océanos para ello en un primer paso
estudiamos todas todas todas las fuentes
de datos de satélite a las que teníamos
acceso y seleccionamos aquella que
pensábamos nos ofrecían las mejores
oportunidades para la detección el
copernicus sentinel 2 esta misión
desarrollada en una colaboración entre
la comisión europea y la agencia
espacial europea está formada por dos
satélites el sentinel 2a que fue lanzado
en el año 2015 y el sentinel 2b que fue
puesto en órbita en el año 2017
entre los dos satélites podemos obtener
una imagen completa del globo terrestre
a 10 metros de resolución cada cinco
días
ambos satélites cuentan con un único
instrumento de observación el denominado
ms que es un multi espectrómetro
este instrumento se asemeja mucho a
cualquiera de las cámaras vegetales
digitales que tenemos hoy en día en
nuestras cámaras de los móviles o
incluso en nuestras cámaras fotográficas
modernas pero hay dos diferencias una la
primera es que en la imagen del satélite
cada pixel equivale a 100 metros
cuadrados de la superficie y dos que
mientras que las cámaras digitales tan
solo pueden ver en tres colores rojo
verde y azul un multi espectrómetro es
capaz de ver en muchos otros colores
incluyendo algunos que son invisibles al
ojo humano como la luz ultravioleta o la
radiación infrarroja
los colores que vemos nos dan
información sobre los objetos que
observamos como por ejemplo su
composición y su localización en el caso
de sentinel 2 y utilizando la
información disponible en todas las
bandas de luz que es capaz de observar
podemos saber para cada pixel de la
imagen si se trata de una zona de bosque
de una carretera o de un campo de
cultivo
podemos saber incluso el tipo de cultivo
como de desarrollado está y sus
necesidades hídricas
ahora bien lo que nosotros realmente
queríamos saber era si sentí en el 2
podría proporcionar información adecuada
para detectar la presencia de plásticos
en el agua las características del
instrumento nos hacían pensar que así
era pero teníamos que demostrarlo con
información contrastada
para ello en un primer lugar intentamos
comprobar si el satélite sería capaz de
ver la mayor estructura de plástico del
planeta que curiosamente se encuentra en
españa'
se la conoce bajo el nombre del mar de
plástico de almería
en la imagen podéis ver la superficie de
la provincia cubierta por invernaderos
gracias a ello hemos podido verificar
qué sentinel 2 es de hecho capaz de ver
el plástico en este caso obtuvimos la
información mirando únicamente a la
radiación infrarroja reflejada por el
plástico y la razón es el gran contraste
que tiene respecto al agua si os fijáis
en la imagen los invernaderos aparecen
de un color blanco brillante mientras
que los pixeles en el mar son de color
negro es justo esta información la que
nos interesa porque quiere decir que
podemos diferenciar entre lo que es
plástico y lo que es agua
ahora bien en el caso de la de la
provincia de almería nos hemos ido a una
situación extrema para saber si el
satélite realmente nos puede ayudar en
este problema
necesitábamos probarlo con
concentraciones de plástico mucho
menores
para ello diseñamos un experimento
trabajando en colaboración con la
universidad del mar egeo en la isla de
lesbos grecia
intentamos verificar si sentí en el 2
sería capaz de ver parcelas artificiales
de plástico del tamaño equivalente a un
píxel pasamos de kilómetros cuadrados en
la provincia de almería a una superficie
de tan sólo 100 metros cuadrados
nuestros colegas construyeron tres
mallas de 10 x 10 metros recubiertas
respectivamente por botellas de refresco
bolsas de plástico y redes de pesca
voluntarios de la universidad las
desplegaron en el mar a la espera de que
el satélite sobrevolar el área nuestro
equipo obtuvo la imagen de sentinel 2 y
la analizamos e intentamos descubrir si
alguna de las tres mallas aparecía
registrada en ella
la buena noticia fue que efectivamente
pudimos identificarlas lo que nos
proporcionó un momento eureka
con la información que obtuvimos del
caso de almería y del experimento de la
isla de lesbos hemos podido desarrollar
por primera vez una metodología capaz de
detectar la cantidad de plásticos que
hay en nuestros océanos y aún más
importante también por primera vez hemos
podido obtener la primera imagen de
satélite mostrando acumulaciones de
basura marina en el mar
en una colaboración con la universidad
de cádiz hemos obtenido información
simultánea de observaciones directas en
el mar junto a observaciones obtenidas
por el satélite la imagen superior es
una adquisición de sentinel 2 sobre el
mar de alborán al sur de españa en ella
podéis observar algunas líneas las
cuales la mayoría de ellas son
acumulaciones de basura marina como
resultado de la acción conjunta del
viento y de las corrientes cuando
seleccionamos una de esas líneas y
analizamos la información que contiene
con nuestra metodología obtenemos todos
esos píxeles brillantes que podéis ver
en la imagen inferior
todos ellos representan acumulaciones de
plástico en la superficie del mar
por tanto es posible usar satélites para
obtener información sobre este problema
medioambiental si es posible y lo hemos
podido demostrar con datos existentes
no obstante sentinel 2 nunca fue
diseñado específicamente para esta tarea
y de hecho tan solo funciona bajo
ciertas condiciones para poder realmente
resolver el enigma de los plásticos en
el mar necesitamos desarrollar un
instrumento nuevo determinar sus
características y saber cómo es el
satélite que ha de llevarlo son
objetivos principales del proyecto de
small y de la agencia espacial europea
sólo juntos podemos desarrollar una
solución a este problema
un equipo internacional de científicos e
ingenieros trabajamos para encontrarlo
en el camino estamos aprendiendo
características claves de los plásticos
en el medio marino como flotan donde se
acumulan y porqué cómo se forman los
fragmentos pequeños a partir de los
grandes estamos aprendiendo las
cantidades más pequeñas que podríamos
llegar a observar averiguando cuáles son
las bandas de luz visible e invisible
que tendríamos que utilizar para
encontrarlo descubriendo que en el
camino vamos a tener que alterar algunos
de los de los conceptos de la ciencia
para hacerlo posible
nos queda mucho camino que recorrer y de
hecho nosotros pensamos que es un camino
muy fascinante yo personalmente espero
que lo que comenzó como una pregunta en
una playa al sur de inglaterra se
convierta en una respuesta a las grandes
preguntas que tenemos sobre las basuras
marinas
aún queda mucho para que una misión sea
posible pero difícil e imposible no son
lo mismo
al fin y al cabo la ciencia es
creatividad con grandes dosis de
curiosidad
yo creo que en nuestra sociedad no solo
es capaz de generar un problema sino que
además es también capaz de encontrar su
solución y que algún día volveremos a
tener playas libres de plástico y
vosotros
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
pero no